This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Criminal is a member of Radiotopia and probably my favorite podcast, depending on the moment you're asking me. And we're presenting a story from them today because it's one of their best and most popular episodes and also in terms of subject. It's the best episode of 99% invisible that we never made. It takes place in Oakland, it's about the built world, liminal spaces, and a statue that fights crime. It was originally broadcast in 2015, but updated in 2019, including an interview with our own Kurt Colstad. It's just delightful. It's called, he's still neutral. Here's criminal.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《Criminal》是Radiotopia旗下的成员，也是我最喜欢的播客之一，具体取决于你什么时候问我。今天我们为大家带来他们的一期节目，因为这是他们最棒、最受欢迎的剧集之一，而且就主题而言，这是《99% Invisible》没能制作出来的最棒的一集。故事发生在奥克兰，关于建筑环境、阈限空间，以及一尊打击犯罪的雕像。它最初于2015年播出，并在2019年进行了更新，其中包括对我们同事库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstad）的采访。这期节目非常精彩。它叫《他依然中立》（He's Still Neutral）。下面请听《Criminal》。
You know, we've had muggings in this neighborhood. You know, we've had muggings and, you know, aggressive behavior, aggravated assaults and all kinds of things over the years here. You know, so it is an issue for lots of people. There's maybe like five or six years ago, the community group gave everybody whistles in case somebody, especially women
你知道，我们这个社区发生过抢劫案。多年来，我们这里发生过抢劫、攻击性行为、严重袭击以及各种各样的事情。所以这对很多人来说是个问题。大概五六年前，社区组织给每个人发了哨子，以防有人，特别是女性
or something were accosted or somebody was following and they just have to blow their whistle and alert other people that something was up. This is Dan Stevenson. He and his wife Lou have lived in Oakland, California for 40 years. They live in a two story, purple Victorian in a neighborhood called East Lake. He says the crimes been an issue there for as long as he can remember.
或者其他人受到骚扰或跟踪，他们只需要吹响哨子，提醒其他人出事了。这位是丹·史蒂文森（Dan Stevenson）。他和妻子卢（Lou）在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市住了40年。他们住在一栋名为东湖（East Lake）社区的紫色两层维多利亚式建筑里。他说，只要他记得，犯罪在那里一直是个问题。
But when you live in a city long enough, you just learn to deal with it. You know, a couple of times some guys tried to get my wallet and just city stuff that, you know, once you live in a city long enough, you've got to at least be a cost of the couple of times or you're not there. Once you know everybody's position, you know, as you go outside, you know who they are and where they are and what they do, it's, you know, there was no hassle. So once you knew that, once you knew that the drug dealer was a drug dealer, you just went about your business and he did his business and you did yours. That's correct, yeah.
但当你在一个城市住得够久，你就会学会如何应对。你知道，有几次有人想抢我的钱包，这都是城市里的常事。你知道，一旦你在城市里住得够久，你至少得被骚扰过几次，否则你就不算真正住在那儿。一旦你了解了每个人的位置，当你出门时，你知道他们是谁、在哪里、在做什么，就不会有麻烦了。所以一旦你了解了这些，一旦你知道那个毒贩就是个毒贩，你就各忙各的，他做他的生意，你做你的。没错，是的。
And you just stayed out of each other's way. Right, I mean, I wouldn't, like I wouldn't call the police. Why? Well, well, first of all, they don't trust the police. I probably trust the drug dealer more than I trust the cop. So that's part of it. Part of it has to do with the times I have called the police. They just don't seem to be able to come in and do it in a common sensical way.
你们互不干扰。对，我的意思是，我不会报警。为什么？嗯，首先，他们不信任警察。我可能比信任警察更信任毒贩。所以这是原因之一。部分原因与我报警的经历有关。他们似乎无法以一种合乎常理的方式来处理问题。
They have to come in like an army or something over somebody selling drugs or what I don't really care about that. It's one thing not to call the cops, and you suspect a guy down the block might be selling drugs. But it's another thing, when there's a man right outside your bedroom window at 3 a.m. This is what happened to Dan and Lou about five years ago.
他们处理起卖毒品的人来就像军队出动一样，或者其他什么，我真的不在乎那个。不报警是一回事，当你怀疑街区那头的人可能在卖毒品时；但当凌晨3点有人站在你卧室窗外时，那是另一回事。这就是五年前发生在丹和卢身上的事。
My wife was here and we went to bed. About 3 a.m., she nudged us, man, and says there's somebody on the deck. Dan says he actually built a special deck to keep random people from wandering up there. There are no stairs. You have to climb partly up a tree and then lift yourself up over the railing.
我妻子当时在那儿，我们上床睡觉了。大约凌晨3点，她推了推我，说甲板上有人。丹说他实际上专门建造了一个特殊的甲板，以防止陌生人乱闯上来。那里没有楼梯。你必须爬上一棵树，然后把自己拉过栏杆。
So I get up and I look out, sure enough there's a guy on the deck. And so I yell through the door and tell him to get off the f***ing deck. And he kind of is totally gone. I mean, the exchange we had was, like, this guy was strung out on something big time. And he was just out to lunch. So my wife wanted me to call the police, but I thought if I call the police they're going to come, this guy's just screwed up. It's not a, he's of no danger that
所以我起床往外看，果然有个家伙在甲板上。于是我隔着门大喊，让他滚出该死的甲板。他整个人都懵了。我的意思是，我们之间的交流是这样的，这家伙显然吸了什么东西，神志不清。他完全不在状态。我妻子想让我报警，但我认为如果我报警，他们会过来，而这家伙只是神志不清。他并没有什么危险，
I could see. He didn't have any weapons or anything. He's just out of it. So we started the talk. It took Dan 45 minutes, but he talked the guy down. Nobody got hurt. If he had gone the official route with the cops, he says it would have been a real pain. And then I had them in up for another two hours, filling out reports with him. By, you know, within 45 minutes, I was back asleep and it was all good.
据我所见。他没有任何武器之类的东西。他只是神志不清。所以我们开始交谈。丹花了45分钟，但他劝说了那个人离开。没有人受伤。他说，如果他走官方途径报警，那会非常麻烦。然后我得再花两个小时跟他们填报告。而现在，45分钟内，我就回去睡觉了，一切都很好。
But even this guy, the most patient, live and let live guy in the neighborhood, eventually hit his limit. And when he got fed up, he did something desperate. Something that makes absolutely no sense to anyone. Maybe least of all, to Dan himself. I'm Phoebe Judge, this is criminal. What wound up pushing Dan over the edge wasn't drug dealers or sex workers. It was garbage, a gigantic pile of garbage.
但即使是这个家伙，社区里最耐心、最奉行“各安天命”的人，最终也到了极限。当他忍无可忍时，他做了一件绝望的事。一件对任何人来说都完全没道理的事。也许对丹自己来说也是如此。我是菲比·贾奇（Phoebe Judge），这是《Criminal》。最终让丹忍无可忍的不是毒贩或性工作者。而是垃圾，一大堆垃圾。
The city put in a traffic diverter across the street from their house. It's about 500 feet from their front door. A concrete divide with space in the middle with trees and and nobody took care of it. Nobody took care of it and so it became a de facto garbage dump. People that were moving decided that that would be a place to move everything they didn't want to take with them. So the stack could be like six eight feet high sometimes with So the stack could be like six, eight feet high sometimes with dressers, mattresses, and garbage, and bags of crap and clothing. I mean, it's just intense. And it's been a big problem with Oakland for years all over the place. You know, somebody will dump whatever they have in your front
市政府在他们家对面安装了一个交通分流器。距离他们前门大约500英尺。那是一个中间有树木的混凝土隔离带，没人管它。没人管它，所以它就成了事实上的垃圾场。搬家的人决定把所有不想带走的东西都扔在那里。所以那堆东西有时能有六到八英尺高，堆满了梳妆台、床垫、垃圾、装满废物的袋子和衣服。我的意思是，这太严重了。多年来，这在奥克兰各地都是个大问题。你知道，如果你不小心，有人就会把他们有的任何东西倒在你前院。
yard if you're not careful. Dan says he'd watch trucks pull up at night and unload mountains of furniture and garbage and he called the city and called and called and called. So you would wake up in the morning sometimes like eight feet to like an eight foot pile of crap. Yeah. And if the city didn't come fast enough, it could get higher. Because once you have, it's like a magnet. Once you've got to stack stuff, other people think, Oh, that is an idea.
丹说他晚上会看到卡车开过来，卸下成堆的家具和垃圾，他给市政府打过电话，打了一次又一次。所以你早上醒来时，有时会看到八英尺高的垃圾堆。是的。如果市政府清理得不够快，它可能会更高。因为一旦有了垃圾，它就像磁铁一样。一旦你堆了东西，其他人就会想，哦，这是个好主意。
And they keep stacking it. So what did you decide to do about it? Well, that was, that is a good question. That was, that is a good question. Lu and I discussed this for quite some time and we came up with the idea of a Buddha to put a Buddha there. Are you Buddhist? No, we have nothing to do with Buddhism at all. But you figured if there's one thing that might help here, it's Buddha.
于是他们继续往上堆。那你决定怎么做？嗯，这是个好问题。这是个好问题。卢和我讨论了很长一段时间，我们想到了放一尊佛像在那里。你们是佛教徒吗？不，我们和佛教完全没关系。但你们觉得如果有什么东西能帮上忙，那就是佛像。
Well, yeah, because he's neutral. I mean, if we threw Christ up there, he's controversial. Everybody's got to deal about him. But Buddha, nobody seems to be that perturbed in general about a Buddha. So Dan and Lou had made up their minds, and it turns out they had a lot of options. We looked at the different ones, and she picked out one that she liked to face me, because they come out of a concrete cast, so some of them look more mellow than others. Lu went off to Aeshardware and picked one out. Which you know she brought
嗯，是的，因为他是中立的。我的意思是，如果我们放个基督像在那儿，那会有争议。每个人对他都有看法。但佛像，似乎没人会对佛像感到不安。所以丹和卢下定了决心，事实证明他们有很多选择。我们看了不同的款式，她挑了一个她觉得看起来对着我的，因为它们是混凝土浇筑的，所以有些看起来比其他的更温和。卢去了Ace五金店挑了一个。她带回家，
home and I liked them you know you look cool to me and then he sat in a basement for about three or four months because I couldn't figure out a way they put them over there without having him stolen or ruined and those things with a really pissed me on. So finally I came up with a plan and I drilled into him and put epoxy rebar into his body and I fixed the buddhist so he'd be looking at our house. In fact, looking through the window where I could look at him.
我挺喜欢的，看起来很酷。然后他在地下室放了三四个月，因为我想不出办法把他放在那儿而不被偷走或损坏，那些东西真的让我很生气。最后我想出了个计划，我钻进他身体里，放入环氧树脂钢筋，把佛像固定住，让他看着我们的房子。事实上，透过窗户我能看到他。
So when I get up in the morning and have my coffee, I could look over and see how he's doing. Are you allowed to do this? It feels like this is breaking some sort of city code. Oh, allowed. That's another thing. It's best not to ask before you do things because it's always no. You kind of just do it and see what happens. Danden tell his neighbors about his plan.
所以当我早上起床喝咖啡时，我可以看过去，看看他怎么样了。你们被允许这样做吗？感觉这违反了某种城市法规。哦，允许。那是另一回事。最好不要在做之前询问，因为答案总是“不行”。你只能直接做了，看看会发生什么。丹没告诉邻居他的计划。
He drags him extension courts from his house and used a drill to affix the Buddha to a slab of concrete. And that was it. And there he was. It's like a surprise. And he just sat there. How long before something happened? It was probably about maybe four months or something of him just sitting there being concrete.
他从家里拖出延长线，用电钻把佛像固定在一块混凝土板上。就这样。他就坐在那儿了。过了多久才发生变化？大概四个月左右，他只是坐在那儿，作为一块混凝土。
But one morning I wake up and look over and boo this white. Some of these come in pain of a soft white. This was someone that kind of carefully done this on purpose. Oh, very carefully. I mean, there's no paint around him or any, I mean, strictly whoever did it took care and painting. And, you know, I thought that's interesting. And then after that, you know, he'd have an orange and pretty soon two oranges and maybe a pair. Just as mysteriously as Dan had installed the statue, people began leaving little gifts, oranges or coins. One day he said he came home from work and there was a big stack of payers. And he had no idea where they were coming from or what they represented.
但有一天早上我醒来，看过去，佛像变白了。有些佛像漆成柔和的白色。这是有人特意小心翼翼地做的。哦，非常小心。我的意思是，他周围没有油漆痕迹，显然做这件事的人很用心。然后在那之后，你知道，他会有个橙子，很快变成了两个橙子，也许还有个梨。就像丹安装雕像一样神秘，人们开始留下小礼物，橙子或硬币。有一天他说他下班回家，看到了一大堆梨。他根本不知道这些东西从哪儿来，代表什么。
I assume now, because of what has happened, the Vietnamese community decided that he needs to be cared for. And from there it just grew to where it is today, which is a total shrine. Yeah, will you describe what the Buddha looks like right now? Well, the Buddha now is like upgraded considerably. I mean, he's gold now. His eyes are painted in and he's got a a gold draped clothing and he's just really top drawer cool looking Buddha. I mean he's he's come a long ways in terms of his dress. Now he sits on the kind of a rock pedestal kind of thing that's not a granite or something. And then he has a house that would, you know,
我现在假设，因为发生的事情，越南社区决定他需要被照顾。从那时起，它就发展成了今天的样子，一个完整的神龛。是的，你能描述一下佛像现在看起来是什么样吗？嗯，佛像现在升级了很多。我的意思是，他现在是金色的。他的眼睛被画上了，他披着金色的衣服，他真的是一个非常高级、看起来很酷的佛像。我的意思是，他在装扮方面进步很大。现在他坐在一种岩石基座上，不是花岗岩之类的。然后他有一个房子，如果你是一个单身且身材娇小的人，你可能住得进去。房子现在围着佛像，所以佛像免受雨淋之类。哦，是的，所以如果你想在那里祈祷，他们经常这样做，你只需要溜进那个小建筑，跪下，佛像就在那儿。
you could probably live in if you were a single person and small. The house is now around Buddha, so Buddha's protected from the rain and such. Oh yeah, and so if you wanted to pray there, which they do constantly, you just slip inside the little building, and you kneel down and Buddha's there.
他还有其他佛的朋友，外面还有一尊大观音，你知道，那是慈悲女神。但你说的祈祷是什么意思？谁会来那里？人们经常来吗？每天早上7点。他们祈祷，他们有一个小响板。他们有一个小东西，就像一个小鼓，他们敲击它，然后他们供奉食物，所有这些人都会来，他们祈祷，然后他们吃东西，形成了一种社区。你有没有出去介绍过自己？哦，他们知道我是谁。所以他们知道你就是那个在2009年从Ace五金店把佛像带回来的人。问题就在这儿。是的，因为在每个节日，他们都会带上一堆食物、水果、酒，还有一次带了一瓶威士忌。作为礼物。谢谢。是的，是的。我一直告诉他们，非常感谢，
And he's got Other friends of boot is you know, and then there's a big quan you in outside, which is you know the goddess of mercy But what what do you what do you mean when they come to pray who who's coming there do people come there often every Every morning at 7 a.m. They pray and they have this little clacker thing They have a little it's like a little drum and they go and they go through that and then know, and they put out food and all these people come and they pray and they go through that and then they eat and they have a kind of a community. Do you ever go out and introduce yourself? Oh, they know who I am. So they know that you, they know that you are the man who brought
但只有我和卢，我们吃不完这些东西。但这些不是你的邻居送来的食物。这些人是从其他社区来拜访佛像的，他们很感激你所做的一切。是的。他们都鞠躬。他们都不会说英语，所以我鞠躬，我们都鞠躬。这对我来说有点尴尬，因为我甚至不知道他们在想什么，但我一直试图告诉他们这是他们的佛像，祝他们好运，然后告别，但他们不太接受。
the Buddha from Ace Hardware in 2009. And there lies the problem. Yes, because at every feast day, they bring over a stack of food and fruit and wine and a bottle of whiskey one time. And just presents for. Thank you. Yes, yeah. And I keep telling them, thanks a lot,
有多少人来？每天有多少人来？你会说来看佛像的人？至少70个。一天。一天，是的。还有游客。他们会敲我的门，他们来自明尼阿波利斯，
but there's only like, Lu and I, and we can't eat all this stuff. But these aren't like your neighbors bringing over food. These are people who are coming to visit Buddha from other neighborhoods and appreciating what you started. Yes. And they all bow. And none of them speak English so I bow and we all bow it's embarrassing kind of for me because I don't even know what they're thinking you know but I keep trying to tell them that it's their Buddha and good luck with him and and Adios but they don't kind of go for that.
有人在Facebook上发了些东西。你知道，他们想在佛像前和我合影。对我来说，无论我多么愤世嫉俗，这就像，到底发生了什么？记住，丹和卢放佛像是一种绝望的尝试，一种真正随机的尝试，旨在减少倾倒垃圾和犯罪。他们意外地为奥克兰的越南佛教社区创造了一个神圣的地方。但这还不是故事的结局。旧的犯罪几乎消失了。
How many people are coming? How many people are coming on a daily basis? Would you say to see the board? Or at least 70. A day. A day, yeah. And then there's also the tourist thing. They'll knock on my door and they're from Minneapolis
毒品交易绝对消失了，卖淫也是。我的意思是，现在离我们区域很远的地方都没有了。但这是一个缓慢的过程，我并没有真正注意到它的发生，甚至在报纸上读到之前都没有从这个角度去想。九月，旧金山纪事报的一位记者写了一篇关于丹和佛像的报道，并向奥克兰警察局询问了该社区最新的犯罪统计数据。他是这样写的：自2012年信徒开始每天前来祈祷以来，
and somebody on Facebook posted something. You know, they want to take my picture with them in front of the booth. It's just for me, you know, as cynical as I am, this is like, what is happening? Remember, Dan and Lou put the Buddha up as a sort of desperate shot in the dark, a truly random attempt to curtail dumping and crime. Any accidentally created a sacred place for members of Oakland's Vietnamese Buddhist community. But that's not the end of the story. Older crime has pretty much disappeared in a sense.
年初至今的总体犯罪率下降了82%。我的意思是，我认为我们都对宗教符号有一些尊重。无论这是我们所信奉的宗教，还是我们是否信奉宗教，我的意思是，像这样的东西确实有些神圣。嗯，我同意。我不知道这是迷信，
The drug dealing definitely is gone, and so's the prostitution. I mean, there's none, zero zero within, you know, quite a distance from our area now. But it's a slow process that I didn't really notice that happening and didn't even think of it in those terms until I read it in the paper. In September, over Porter for the San Francisco Chronicle did a story on Dan and the Buddha and asked the Oakland Police Department for the updated crime statistics for the neighborhood. Here's what he wrote. Since 2012, when worshipers began showing up for daily prayers,
还是佛教说“别搞乱这个”或者其他什么，我不知道。但它奏效了。所以你是对的。我认为人们确实有一种尊重或恐惧的感觉。我不知道。我想这不重要。犯罪率下降了。82%。我在2015年采访了丹·史蒂文森。在过去的四年里，佛像周围的事情变得越来越大。这全归功于一个越南家庭。这是维娜·沃（Vina Vow）和她的丈夫，在他们儿子Kokvo的翻译帮助下。每天，早上七点，每天，四点，一天两次，
overall year to date crime has dropped by 82%. I mean, I think we all have some respect for religious symbols. Whether it's the religion that we ascribe to, whether we ascribe to a religion at all, I mean, there's something rather sacred about things like this. Well, I agree. And I don't know if it's superstition
七点和四点。六点我回家。每天，我都在这儿。我让我丈夫在这儿。你家怎么样？我放了一尊佛像在这儿。我放了佛像。在这儿。我爸爸说这都是丹的功劳。
or whether Buddhist says don't f*** with this or what, I have no idea. But it works. So you're right. I think people do have a feeling of either respect or fear. I don't know. I guess it doesn't matter. Crime is death. 82%. I spoke with Dan Stevenson in 2015. In the past four years, things have only gotten bigger at the Buddha. It's all thanks to one Vietnamese family. Here's Vina Vow and her husband with some translation help from their son, Kokvo. Every day, morning, seven o'clock, every day, four, two, one day, two times,
我们这里有一个和平的神龛。让邻居们平静下来。所以我们有平静的心境和安宁。维娜说，有些早晨，她来的时候发现其他人带来了新的香和新鲜的花。她说这是一个和平的地方。如果你想亲自去看看，现在很容易找到。佛像在谷歌地图上。只需搜索“奥克兰的佛像”（The Buddha of Oakland）。它甚至有评论。
seven o'clock, and four o'clock. Six o'clock I go home. Every day, I make over here. I make my husband make over here. How's your home then? I'm put a Buddha in make it over here. How's your home, Dan? I'm put in the Buddha. In the Raka, here. My dad says it was all days to Dan here.
一个说，最好的佛像。它甚至有评论。一个说，最好的佛像。这超出了我最疯狂的想象。我当时根本无法想象。我们上周给丹打了电话，看看有什么新情况。对于一个混凝土花园佛像来说，这简直太疯狂了，它原本只是苗圃里货架上的一堆佛像之一。一路上发生了各种各样的事情。汽车会错过拐角或者撞到什么东西，
We have a peaceful shrine here. And make the neighbors calm down a little bit. So we have a peaceful mindness and tranquility. Venus says some mornings, she arrives to find that other people have brought new incense and fresh flowers. She says it's a peaceful place. If you'd like to visit yourself, it's easy to find these days. The Buddha is on Google Maps. Just search for the Buddha of Oakland. It even has reviews.
或者多年来有一些破坏行为，但每次发生什么事，他们的反应就是把它做得更大。所以它过去只是一个小建筑，然后变成了两个，然后有人打破了雕像之类的，所以变成了三个，然后四个，然后有一个小棚子，我想你可以称之为棚子，但一个小侧楼。我明白那个建筑里的人是战神或保护神，或者自他们放进去以来做得相当不错的人。他们让事情保持平静。你有没有坐下来想过，嗯，那真是了不起。那真是一个好主意。嗯，卢和我有这个想法，
One says, best Buddha. It even has reviews. One says, best Buddha. This is beyond my wildest thought pattern. I just couldn't, I wouldn't even fan them at that time. We called Dan last week to see what was new. It's insane in terms of what has happened to a concrete garden Buddha, which was just on the shelf with a whole bunch of other Buddhas all just sitting there in the nursery. And different things have happened along the way. Cars will miss the corner or something and hit something
我们俩都没指望太多，除了也许它能改变垃圾问题，它确实做到了。但这已经变得离谱了。还有人敲你的门，过来说，嗨，你是那个人吗？你是那个著名的佛像丹吗？我基本上会遇到这种情况，不是很多，但比我预期的要多。还有人们在街上拦住我，他们甚至离我家很远，他们有一个参考点。或者在某个生意场所，
or there's been some vandalism over the years but every time anything happens, the response is they make it bigger. So it used to be just a small one little building and then it's two, and then somebody tried they broke a statue or something, so then it's three and then four, and then there's a little shed, I guess you'd call it a shed, but a little side building. I understand that the guy in that building is the God of war or the protection or God of somebody that has done pretty good jobs since they put them in. They keep things calm. Do you ever sit back and think to yourself, well, that was really something. That was quite an idea I had. Well, Lu and I had the idea,
某个地方会认出我。说实话，我甚至不知道他们从哪儿找到的信息，或者他们怎么知道是我，但他们确实知道了。而且，我想这很好。对我来说，我放了佛像，我就完成了。你知道，剩下的这些是别人的工作。你知道，所以我帮忙开始了它。你知道，而且，卢和我之前讨论了很多，因为她比我积极得多。所以我总是会看他们会怎么毁掉它，
neither one of us expected much of anything except maybe it was shift the garbage and it did that. But then this has been outrageous. Do you still have anybody knocking on your door coming and saying, Hi, are you the guy? Are you the famous Dan of the Buddha? I pretty much get that, not a whole lot, but more than I would expect at this point in time. And also people stopping me on the streets somehow, they've not even close to my house and they have a reference point. Or somebody in some business,
而不是可能性，而她更是一个看重可能性的人。你知道，她是正确的。她绝对是。她在很多事情上都是对的。不仅仅是佛像。我们花了很多时间谈论灵性和更伟大的事情。她在大多数事情上都说得很准。比我领先很多，你知道，就是，比我领先很多。她积极得多。这是我们的，我们有119集。这是我们有史以来最受欢迎的剧集之一。
some place will recognize me. I don't even know where they find the information out, tell you the truth, or how they figured it was me, but they do. And it's, I guess it's nice. To me, I put the boot in and I'm done. You know, the rest of this is somebody else's work. You know, so I helped start it. You know, and, you know, and Loon, I had lots of discussions before, you know, we did it because she's much more positive than I am. So I would always look at how are they going to wreck it as
哇。你认为为什么这个故事能打动人？嗯，我会说它是积极的。这是一个积极的故事，关于，你知道，真正的希望。我的意思是，它存在于我们生活的世界中，这真的让我很震惊。这就像，它几乎与我不断听到的所有东西背道而驰，但事实并非如此，因为它到处都在发生。只是我们大多数时候只听到坏的部分。所以这只是一种给予。
opposed to the possibilities and she's much more of a possibility person. You know, she was right. She definitely was. She's right on a lot of things. Not just the Buddha. We spend a lot of time talking spirituality and the greater things. And she's pretty much on the mark on most of it. Way ahead of me, you know, just, you know, way ahead of me. She's much more positive. This is one of our, we have 119 episodes. And this is one of our most popular episodes ever.
他们参与的人，我的意思是，他们给予，这是他们信仰和东西的给予。而来的人只是尊重这一点。我的意思是，我们现在有，我没记录，但现在有旅游巴士来参观。这里有一辆巨大的巴士过来，试图穿过街道，你知道，就巴士而言相当小，把人们放下，拍照之类的。这令人印象深刻。
Wow. Why do you think the story gets to people? Well, I would say that it's positive. It's a positive story of, you know, actually hope. I mean, it truly blows my mind that it exists in the world that we live in. It's just like, it's almost counter to everything that I hear it constantly, but it's not really because it's happening everywhere. It's just that we only hear the bad parts most of the time. So it's just kind of a giving thing.
我从未意识到这样的事情怎么能这样，你知道。我的意思是，我认为它确实激励人们去做更好的事情。你生活中还有其他什么事吗？太多了，说不完。我一直很忙。菲比在之后会和我们的库尔特·科尔斯特德谈谈。我叫库尔特·科尔斯特德，我是《99% Invisible》的数字总监和制片人，我为这个节目制作剧集、文章和其他内容，这个节目是关于设计和建筑环境的。库尔特说，丹的佛像可以通过一种被称为“敌对建筑”（hostile architecture）的设计概念来观察。
The people that they're involved with are, I mean, they give, it's a giving of their beliefs and their stuff. And people that come just respect that. I mean, we now have, I haven't kept track of it, but there's tour buses now that come to visit. And here's this huge bus coming, trying to get through the streets, you know, rather smaller in terms of buses, to drop people off, to take photos and stuff. It's impressive.
敌对建筑是努力“设计出犯罪”（design out crime）的一个方面。改变公共空间的某些东西以阻止不受欢迎的行为。几年前，德国汉堡的一个社区团体对他们社区里持续不断的尿味感到厌烦，那是一个挤满了夜总会的社区，他们决定用一种特殊的油漆进行反击。这种油漆是为船只设计的，不会吸收液体。
I never realized how something like this could be this, you know. I mean, it certainly inspires people to better things, I think. Anything else going on in your life? Too much to mention. I keep busy all the time. Phoebe talks with our own Kurt Kohlstedt after this. My name is Kurt Kohlstedt and I am the digital director and a producer at 99% invisible and I work on episodes and articles and other things for this show which is all about design and built environments. Kurtz's Dan's Buddha can be viewed through the lens of a design concept known as hostile architecture.
如果它不吸收液体，他们想，也许它能排斥尿液。他们是对的。当有人从夜总会走出来试图在墙上小便时，他们的尿液“反弹”回了他们身上。其他城市也纷纷效仿。城市实施设计变更，比如在窗台上安装尖刺，
Hostile architecture is one facet of efforts to quote, design out crime. Change something about public space in order to deter unwanted behavior. A few years ago, a community group in Hamburg, Germany got fed up with the constant smell of urine in their neighborhood, a neighborhood packed with nightclubs, and they decided to fight back with a special kind of paint. This paint is designed to be used on boats and will not absorb liquid.
以防止人们坐下。长椅上的扶手不仅仅是为了给我们一个休息手肘的地方。它们还防止人们躺下。敌对建筑经常因其不够微妙以及试图驱逐城市无家可归者而受到批评。虽然城市进来并试图从上到下改变公众的行为，通常以激进的方式，但也有很多公民介入的例子，比如丹·史蒂文森和他的佛像，从下到上实施改变，这些改变可能是合法的，也可能不是。库尔特说有很多有趣的例子。
If it weren't absorbed liquid, they thought, maybe it will repel urine. They were right. When someone walked out of a nightclub and attempted to relieve themselves on a wall, their urine quote, bounced back onto them. Other cities have followed suit. Cities implement design changes like spikes on window
所以，停车位公园（parklets）本质上是改造成小公园的公共停车位。这个想法在旧金山的一个名为Rebar的团体制作了一个停车位公园后变得非常大，它在网上疯传。本质上他们所做的就是铺了一些草皮，在草地上放了一些家具，给停车计时器投了币，然后他们只是等着
cells to prevent people from sitting down. Arm rests on benches aren't just to give us a place to rest our elbows. They also prevent people from lying down. Hostile architecture is often criticized for being less than subtle and it's attempt to drive away a city's homeless population. While cities come in and try to alter the public's behavior from the top down, often in aggressive ways, there are also plenty of examples of citizens stepping in, like Dan Stevenson with his Buddha implementing changes from the bottom up, changes that may or may not be legal. Kurt says there are a lot of playful examples of this.
看看会发生什么。有些人停下来并真正使用了这个停车位公园。正如他们讲述的故事，一个交通警察也过来了，说，嘿，你知道，我得给你们开罚单，他们说，不，我们合法租了这个位置，他们设法让他离开了。所以通过这种漏洞，他们通过支付租金、支付计时器合法地占用了这个空间，这
So, parklets are essentially public parking spaces converted into little parks. The idea got really big after this group called Rebar in San Francisco, made a parklet, and it went really viral online. And essentially all they did was they rolled out some sod and they put some furniture out in the grass and they fed the meter and then they just weighed
只是思考这种公共空间的另一种方式。我们认为它是汽车的空间。他们认为它是公园的空间。这并不是法律设计用来容纳的东西，然而他们让法律为他们工作，并为公众工作。但外面有很多事情有点游走在合法或非法的边缘，我在想消防栓。对，是的。消防栓是那种经典的东西，你见过，每个人都
to see what would happen. And some people stopped by and actually used the parklet. And as they tell the story, a traffic cop came by too and was saying, hey, you know, I'm gonna have to write your ticket and they said, no, we've legally rented this spot and they kind of got him to go away. So through this kind of loophole, they legally occupy this space by paying the rent, paying the meter, which
看过电影里孩子们在街上玩耍的场景，消防栓是那种经典的东西，你见过，每个人都看过电影里孩子们在街上玩耍，消防栓喷出水，每个人都玩得很开心。而且，你知道，这是其中之一。如果我们思考一下，我们都知道这可能在技术上是非法的。事实上，通常确实如此。你可能会因为这样做而收到罚款。但也有一些情况，你知道，消防员实际上会过来，像帮助人们打开消防栓。所以它有点来回波动。而且它追溯到，所以有一次热浪
is just a different way to think about this kind of public space. We think about it as a space for cars. They thought about it as a space for a park. It's not really what the law was designed to accommodate, and yet they're making the law work for them, and work for the public. But there are a lot of things out there that kind of skirt this line of legal or illegal, and I was thinking about like fire hydrants. Right, yeah. Fire hydrants are kind of this classic thing, where you've seen, everybody's
在19世纪末的纽约市，市政府只是说，你知道，我们要打开消防栓，我们要分发冰块。我们要基本上帮助城市降温，让人们保持安全和快乐。所有这些来回，它是非法的吗？它是非法的吗？最终，纽约想出了这种新颖的妥协，他们制造了控制水流的盖子。它使使用更安全，浪费更少的水，但它仍然让人们打开
seen scenes of movies where kids are playing in the street, and the fire hydrants are kind of this classic thing, where you've seen, everybody's seen scenes of movies where kids are playing in the street and the fire hydrants pouring water and everybody's having fun. And, you know, it's one of those things. We all know if we think about it, that's probably technically illegal. And in fact, it usually is. You can get fines for doing that. But there are also cases where, you know, the firefighters will actually come along and like help people open up the hydrants. So it kind of goes back and forth. And it goes way back to, so there is this heat wave
这些消防栓。所以这是城市的一种接受，人们会这样做。让我们也许尝试找到一种方法，让他们可以更安全地做到这一点，而不是像过去那样鲁莽地做。在芝加哥，当我长大的时候，夏天会变得非常热，会有消防栓被打开。
in the late 1800s in New York City where the city just said, you know, we're going to open up the hydrants, we're going to distribute ice. We're going to basically help cool down the city and and keep people safe and happy. And all this back and forth, is it illegal? Is it illegal? Eventually, New York came up with this kind of novel compromise where they created these caps that control the flow of water. It makes it so it's safer to use, it's waste less water, but it still lets people crack
我清楚地记得作为一个非常小的女孩，水非常有力。我的意思是，这，太多了。它太强大了。对于一个七岁的女孩来说，从这个东西里出来的水力太大了。但它有一些东西，城市，消防员，警察
open these hydrants. So it's this kind of acceptance by the city that people are gonna do this. Let's maybe try to find a way that they can do it more safely and not just kind of recklessly, like it's been done in the past. In Chicago, when I grew up, it would get really hot in the summers and there would be fire hydrants that would be opened.
都在承认，嘿，我们只需要度过今天，因为现在是115度。所以让我们变通一下这些规则，让我们聚在一起。感觉真的很棒。是的，我认为这就是吸引力的一部分。它打破了这些障碍。就像我们认为它，你知道，哦，城市基础设施是城市的东西，我们不允许碰它。
And I remember very clearly being a really little girl and it's really powerful, the water. I mean, this is, it's too much. It's almost too powerful. The force of the water coming out of this thing for like a seven-year-old girl to be playing in. But there was something about it that the city, that the firefighters, that the police
而这些人在这里是为了执行法律和扑灭火灾。但是是的，这很美。当这些障碍打破，我们意识到，现在城市是属于我们所有人的。这里有一种新颖的方式或不同的方式来利用它的基础设施。人们玩弄环境的其他例子还有什么？
were acknowledging, hey, we just got to get through today, because it's 115. So let's bend these rules, let's all just come together. And it felt really nice. Yeah, and I think that is part of the appeal. It's like it breaks down these barriers. Like we think it, you know, oh, city infrastructures for city stuff, and we're not allowed to touch that.
我的意思是，我特别着迷的一种类型是，它通常被称为“游击园艺”（guerrilla gardening）。这个想法可以追溯到70年代，它始于人们接管纽约的废弃地块并将它们变成社区花园。它最初是非法的。其中一些花园后来变得合法了。
And these people are here to enforce laws and put out fires. But yeah, that's kind of beautiful. When those barriers break down and we realize, now the city is all of ours. And here's a novel way or a different way to put its infrastructure to use. What are other examples of people playing with their environment?
所以旧金山有一个团体自称“游击嫁接者”（guerrilla grafters），他们对游击园艺的方法与大多数人不同。他们不是试图种植新东西或接管废弃空间，而是积极地将结果实的树枝嫁接到不结果实的树上。
I mean, one of the types that I'm particularly fascinated by is sort of, it's generally known as guerrilla gardening. And this idea, it goes back to the 70s and it sort of started with people taking over abandoned lots in New York and turning them into community gardens. And it started out illegal. And some of those gardens have since become legal.
所以本质上，他们正在把这些观赏树变成城市里的果树。起初你会想，嘿，谁会有问题呢，对吧？我的意思是，他们在没有食物的地方创造了食物，这就是他们的看法。但事实证明，这些树之所以是观赏性的是有原因的。城市不希望它们吸引动物。他们不希望这些水果掉下来造成混乱，然后城市不得不清理。所以这些嫁接者最终不得不以某种方式在雷达下工作。等等，所以告诉我他们到底在做什么，这种游击园艺。他们把苹果树枝放在枫树上？
So there's this group in San Francisco that call themselves the guerrilla grafters, and their approach to guerrilla gardening is sort of different from most. Instead of trying to plant new things or take over abandoned spaces, they're actively grafting fruit bearing branches onto non-fruit bearing trees.
我真的不明白你可以这样做，但本质上你可以在现有的树上切一个小口，附上一小段接穗，一段活的树枝，然后它会在原地愈合，成为那棵现有树的一部分。所以你不会把整棵树变成一棵果树，但你给那棵树增加了一个结果实的树枝。然后随着时间的推移，你知道，这些开始结出果实。而且想法是，你知道，任何人都可以走过来，只是说，哦，这棵树上有个苹果。然后随着时间的推移，你知道，这些开始结出果实。而且想法是，你知道，任何人都可以走过来，只是说，哦，这棵树上有个苹果。我可以吃那个。而且它很微妙。这是一种微妙的干预。而且可能没人会
So essentially, they're turning these ornamental trees into fruit bearing trees in the city. And at first you'd think, hey, who would have a problem with that, right? I mean, they're creating food where there was no food before and that's kind of their take on it. But it turns out that those trees are ornamental for a reason. The city doesn't want them attracting animals. They don't want to like have these fruits falling and making messes that the city then has to clean up. And so these grafters end up having to work kind of under the radar. Wait, so just tell me exactly what they're doing, this guerrilla gardening. They're putting like an apple branch on like a maple tree?
知道，直到突然整个街区都有了水果。这些都是例子。丹和他的佛像包括在内，人们有点跳出框框思考。是的。而且我认为这是关于所有这些最有趣的事情，对吧？就像我们，我们有一种思考城市的方式。我们认为城市是规划好的东西，如果你想让某些东西改变，也许你和市议会谈谈，但这些项目表明，有很多机会可以尝试，你知道，和丹·史蒂文森一起做，你可以说，我只是要去拿这个佛像，把它插在地上，看看会发生什么，你知道，请求原谅而不是许可。
I did not really understand that you could do this, but essentially you can make a little cut into an existing tree and attach a little sion, a living branch, and then it heals in place and becomes part of that existing tree. So you don't convert the entire tree into a fruit bearing tree, but you add a fruit bearing branch to that tree. And then over time, you know, these start producing fruit. And the idea is that, you know, anybody can walk up and just kind of say, oh, there's an apple on this tree. And then over time, you know, these start producing fruit. And the idea is that, you know, anybody can walk up and just kind of say, Oh, there's an apple on this tree. I can eat that. And it's subtle. It's a subtle intervention. And probably nobody would
而且我发现关于丹·史蒂文森的例子非常迷人的是，人们也喜欢它，对吧？人们来照顾它并爱它，它已经成为社区的一部分，你知道，佛教徒和非佛教徒似乎都很欣赏。你刚回到那里。你刚看到它。你昨晚就在那儿。我是。
be the wiser until suddenly there was fruit all along the block. These are all examples. Dan and his Buddha included of people kind of thinking outside the box. Yes. And I think that's, that's the most interesting thing about all of this, right? Like we, we have a way that we think of cities. We think of cities as being planned things where if you want to get something to change, maybe you talk to a city council, but what these kinds of projects show is that there are a lot of opportunities to try, you know, with Dan Stevens and to it, and you could say, I'm just going to go get this Buddha and stick it to the ground and see what happens, you know, ask for forgiveness and not permission.
而且这很神奇。我的意思是，在晚上你可以从几个街区外看到它。我的意思是，有这些闪烁的灯光，这些是螺旋状的闪烁灯光。当你靠近时，你真的能闻到香的味道。而且有所有这些不同的佛像，有些是白色的，有些是漆过的，它们大小不同，材质不同。而最初的佛像实际上并不是中心佛像。
And what I find really fascinating about the Dan Stevens and example is that people love it, too, right? People come and care for it and love it, and it's become part of the community that, you know, Buddhists and non-Buddhist alike seem to really appreciate. You just went back there. You just saw it. You were just there last night. I was.
他有点坐在旁边的一个小棚子里。所以他引发了这件事，但他不再是它的核心了。它只是被接管并成长了。而且，你知道，在主建筑后面，有几个房间，我想，你知道，是保持区域清洁工作的一部分。所以它确实在做丹·史蒂文森想要它做的事。它让人们投入并保持区域清洁。
And it's amazing. I mean, at night you can see it from blocks away. I mean, there are these blinking lights, these are spiraling blinking lights. When you get close, you can really smell the incense. And there are all these different budas, summer white and some are painted and their different sizes, different materials. And the original buda isn't actually the central buda.
但它也走出了自己的路。而且真正疯狂的是，我昨晚刚发现这个，如果你转过弯，离这个神龛只有一两个街区远，是另一个。它就像同一个东西的较小版本，但它在成长。我简直可以想象在五到十年内，这些可能到处都是，对吧？所以，我不知道。而且我简直可以想象在五到十年内，这些可能到处都是，对吧？
He's sort of sitting off to one side in this smaller hut. So he kind of sparked this thing, but he's not at the heart of it anymore. It's just been taken over and grown. And, you know, behind the main building, there are a couple of rooms, which I assume, you know, is part of the Keeping the Area Clean effort. So it is doing what Dan Stevens and wanted it to. It's getting people invested and keeping the area clean.
所以我不知道，我认为这是，你知道，从这一个佛像开始的东西已经变得大得多了。《Criminal》由劳伦·斯波勒（Lauren Sporer）和菲比·贾奇（Phoebe Judge）创作。他们的资深制片人是纳迪亚·威尔逊（Nadia Wilson），音频混音由罗伯·拜尔斯（Rob Byers）和迈克尔·雷菲尔德（Michael Rayfield）完成。特别感谢埃里克·梅内尔（Eric Menel）、亚历克斯·布莱尔（Alex Blair）和科比·麦克唐纳（Kobe Mcdonald）。如果这是你第一次听到《Criminal》的故事，我其实有点羡慕你，因为你现在有119集可以去深入探索和享受。在thisiscriminal.com找到它们。
But it's also taken out a life of its own. And what's really crazy, I just found this last night, if you turn the corner, just another block and a half away from this shrine, is another one. And it's like a smaller version of the same thing, but it's growing. And I could just imagine in like five or ten years, these could just be all over the neighborhood, right? So, I don't know. And I could just imagine in like five or ten years, these could just be all over the neighborhood, right?
《99% Invisible》是旧金山KLW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心广播街制作。我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。Instagram和Reddit上也有。
So I don't know, I think it's, you know, what started with this one Buddha has become something much, much bigger. The Criminal is created by Lauren Sporer and Phoebe Judge. Their senior producer is Nadia Wilson, audio mix by Rob Byers and Michael Rayfield. Special thanks to Eric Menel, Alex Blair and Kobe Mcdonald. If this is the first time you've heard a story from criminal, I actually kind of envy you because you now have 119 episodes to go dive in and enjoy. Find them at this is criminal.com.
但我欢迎你深入探索并尝试一个你还没听过的故事，在99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
99% of visible is a project of KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show in joint discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Run Instagram and read it too.
99% Invisible是旧金山KLW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的Radio Row制作。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。你可以在radiotopia.fm找到所有这些节目。你可以在Facebook上找到关于本节目的联合讨论。你可以在推特上关注我Roman Mars，以及节目账号99PI org。也可以关注我们的Instagram和Reddit。
But I welcome you to dive in and try a story you haven't heard at 9NIPI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我欢迎你深入探索，在99PI.org上尝试听听你还没听过的故事。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。